hello everyone and welcome to round
seven uh or rather round eight yeah this
is round eight of the 2021 norway chess
it's magnus carlson versus richard
rapport and uh rapport is still leading
the tournament magnus is trailing and
rapport has a three and a half point
lead so if you remember in the first
half of the tournament rapport lost the
magnus but not in the classical time
section in the classical they drew the
game and then magnus won the armageddon
game so now uh if a rapper can hold
magnus to a draw or even win the game in
classical that's not only going to do
wonders for his rating but also will
just propel him uh further away into the
world top five of the classical chess
elite so it's quite a game a lot to
cover let's check it out and don't worry
we are going to cover all of the games
that were played today so magnus has the
white pieces and he opens with e4 we
have e5 by rapport knight to f3 knight
to c6 and now bishop to b5 going for the
royal lopez
and knight to f6 the berlin defense is
on the board we have d3 and now rapport
already goes for uh for a beautiful
beautiful surprise move so here you
either play a d6 so sort of a closed
system or play bishop to d5 bishop to c5
before closing the position with the d6
but robert plays knight the e7 it's a
it's a very nice move it's called the
mortimer variation of the of the berlin
and it uh well it kind of offers the e5
pawn but you can't grab this pawn this
is not why why this is played if you
grab the pawn then we just uh win a
piece here we just play c6 and it's game
over black wins so now your bishop is
attacked you have to move it it doesn't
matter where you move it just queen a5
check and then you lose this greedy
knight on e5 so of course magnus doesn't
to go for this after knight e7 he did
consider the position for
uh some time because there's so much to
consider you could go knight to c3 you
could play bishop back to c4 as you know
that c6 is coming you could strike in
the center with the d4 yes it loses your
tempo but black also lost the tempo by
playing knight to e7 but magnus just
calmly castles uh and now what do you
play here uh well c6 of course this is
uh in all of the lines bishop to a4 and
now knight the g6 so the two knights are
now very nicely placed on the king side
and you will have very nice support if
you ever want to execute the d5 the
bishop will be developed somewhere e7 c5
and then you're gonna castle and you
will have a very enjoyable game so here
magnus again spent some time played rook
to e1 and now bishop to e7 we have d4
not waiting any longer
and now comes d6 so just defending this
pawn and now you could capture this but
this doesn't really do anything for you
just captures capture so you could trade
queens but black is very happy here
white achieved really nothing black
still has the bishop's pair and
well there are no weaknesses in the
position so instead magnus just
continues with c3 and now robert castle
so we have knight beat to d2 and the
situation on the clock is both players
are playing relatively fast uh uh robert
has some 10 minutes more on the clock
than magnus we have h6 and now knight to
f1 magnus's knight is also coming to g3
uh we rook the e8 and now knight the g3
and now a5 uh will be used later on
for for b5 to be executed and it
prevents white from going b for a4 and
so on so here bishop back to c2 and now
queen to c7 so just nicely developing
pieces we have a4 by magnus and now
bishop to d7 now preparing rook to b8
and then b5 and starting to play on the
queen side we have h3 by magnus and now
comes b5 so striking in the
uh here on the queen side uh and now
what do you play well magnus says all
right i don't really care about this you
can push b4 if you want to i'm just
going to continue development bishop to
e3 and now rook a to b8 so now you know
that b4 is coming magnus plays queen to
d2 prepares for this and now b4 so what
can you play here well you could maybe
advance the pawn all the way to c4 but
then you allow a move like b3 could be a
very annoying pawn later on so instead
we have bishop to d3 now saying all
right if you want to push this pawn all
the way you can but now it doesn't
really come with tempo so yeah i mean
it's uh it is possible but then we can
play bishop to c4 and you know it could
it could become a liability you can only
defend this pawn with pieces not with
pawns so instead after bishop to d3 we
have b captures on c3 by rapport uh b
captures and now bishop to e6
we have queen to c2 by magnus now uh
rooks are probably getting doubled on
the b file so magnus wants to have some
support on the b1 square but also adding
more supports to the e4 square so rook
to b7 and now knight to f1 uh we have
knight the h5 going after uh this uh
well very nice f4 square a knight will
do wonders there and then maybe some
attacking chances will be possible
knight to f4 maybe bishop captures an h3
knight captures you know sacrifice
something start an attack against
carlson's king maybe if queen comes to
d7 could become uh very very good for uh
for him so knight to d2 now going for
that um
c4 square and now knight h to f4 so
attacking the bishop here of course
we're not going to just give up our
light square bishop so bishop to a6
trying to trick rapport a little bit uh
but the rapper doesn't of course fall
for it it's not a big trick but it is a
little trick here for example if you go
rook the b6 then we just bring the
bishop back bishop to f1 and now we have
a lot of threats here like d5 attacking
the bishop and the rook here and now
black would have to waste a move and
then well it's sort of like we've won uh
one a move uh black's position did not
change and we got our bishop to f1 and
now we can play some like rook e to b1
so a slight improvement it would be uh
but okay rook b back to b8 by rapport
and now magnus trades in the center d
captures on e5 d captures and now rook
uh a to b1 so countering black's rook on
b8 and now bishop back to d7
and here the situation on the clock is
uh magnus some 38 minutes on the clock
at upwards some 31 minutes on the clock
i know a lot of you guys really just
want to start grabbing here on h3 but we
don't have any support for example if
captures captures captures with checking
h2
there's no good way to continue this
attack there's really nothing for us
here so we need a few more moves to
prepare if such a such an idea can even
be considered so after bishop to d7
magnus has to decide whether he wants to
go uh with the knight to c4 uh which is
kind of what uh rapport is planning
after bishop to d7 but he doesn't he
abandons the plan of knight to c4 and
just brings the bishop back if knight to
c4 we can just play bishop back to e6
and now yes you can go to b6 it seems
like a very nice square but the tactics
work in black's favor we can just
capture this bishop and after knight
captures bishop to c5 now we're
attacking the knight twice and once the
knight moves let's say knight to c4 now
we play queen to a7 and now we have an
attack on the bishop and that and an
attack on this f2 pawn uh but not only
that okay the queen guards the f2 pawn
but the bishop here does not have a way
out how are you going to save this
bishop so that's the kind of thing that
lurks in the position so magnus abandons
this he goes bishop back to c4
and now we have knight to e6 now this
knight is coming all the way to f8 and
then maybe we're going to have a
a bishop trait along this diagonal so
queen to a2 now magnus says nope this
knight is not moving an inch otherwise
bishop captures on f7 is coming
and now knight to h4 so also a plan uh
just trading off a pair of knights
magnus says okay we have knight
characters bishop captures and now
knight to f3 again uh forcing this
bishop to move back bishop to e7 and now
rook b to d1 so shifting the rook from
the open b file to the open d file and
this bishop is now only defended by the
queen so the queen could become
overloaded if not careful so bishop back
to c8 by rapport
and now queen to c2 by magnus yeah so
now uh the queen bishop battery no
longer exists here and rapport takes
this opportunity to shift his knight
over to f8 and now the bishop will be
reactivated via the e6 square so rook to
d2 by magnus and now bishop to e6 we
have queen back to a2 he's saying okay
if you want to trade here we can trade
but i want my queen to capture on c4 so
i have constant pressure on c6 it's a
weak pawn uh so you know
uh definitely that's how we're gonna
trade so rook e the d8 offering a trade
of rooks here and magnus just captures
we have rook captures bishop captures
and now rook to d1 uh bishop back to e7
and now uh as you can see black is uh uh
holding the position very nicely not
much is happening here but he has to
thread very carefully and magnus just
grabs more space with h4 as he usually
does
we have rook to d8 offering a trade of
rooks but magnus declines and just goes
back rook to b1 he says all right if you
want to trade we can trade but we're
gonna trade on b8 uh so rapport goes
back we have rooked a b8 and now magnus
goes for the trade rook captures queen
captures and now g3 now the pawns are
nicely defended and now the knight can
move you don't have to keep an eye on
the h4 pawn
and now we have bishop the d8 like i
said if you trade here this only helps
white you're going to have constant
pressure on this pawn and you're going
to well not there obviously but
black has a lot of pawns here to defend
white also has a lot of pawns here to
defend if you uh
consider it it's basically a symmetrical
pawn structure but white is if this
exchange would occur white would have um
a lot more space to go with so after g3
we have bishop to d8 now shifting the
bishop over to this diagonal
and now king to g2 by magnus so
improving the position of the king a
little bit uh bishop to c7 and only now
uh after all of the uh options were uh
uh
well
sort of depleted magnus goes for this
trade bishop captures knight captures
and now the queen lands on c4 so now
we're putting pressure on this pawn and
black has to defend it so how do you do
it queen b8 queen to a8 queen to e8 all
of this is defending the pawn rapper
chooses the e8 square and now magnus
just grabs more space on the king side
as he usually does and now king to h7
and interestingly both players are
already down to 10 minutes and we are uh
we we've reached move 40 so we do have
increment but you know
it's not easy playing under at these
these conditions um you know uh
definitely so here magnus goes queen to
d3 and this was a special moment in the
game uh he could uh
avoid giving black this opportunity by
playing something like knights to e1 or
knight to d2 just moving the knight
first but he played queen to d3 and uh
he allowed rapport a very very sneaky
maneuver but rapper doesn't go for it
maybe he didn't see it maybe he saw it
and he didn't want to
you know allow the position to open up
it's hard to imagine if you see such a
move that you don't play it so here
rapper played queen to e7 but f5 is the
move that uh i might even use this as a
thumbnail uh f5 is the move that uh
rapport
did not play like i said i have not
heard any interviews uh so maybe maybe
he saw it maybe he just decided against
it but it's uh it seems deadly uh
because what do you play uh if you
capture on f5 than just e4 and black
well is close to winning the either
you're going to lose material or you
capture here and then you lose even more
material this comes with check the
knight is defended and you will lose the
queen here there is no defense here you
have to capture
there is really nothing here you can
capture like this and then after bishop
captures bishop captures you will have
bishop and knight for a queen but there
are so many pawns all over the board
that this is no compensation for white
so what you would have to do after f5 is
not capture this pawn there's no
question about it we cannot capture this
uh but then again
if you just ignore it there's really no
good way to play and f4 is coming
whatever white plays f4 is coming so
maybe something that the rapper could
have gone for but okay after queen d3 he
played queen to e7 and now magnus moves
the knight probably he spotted that you
know you do not want to meet f4 f5 with
the knight being on f3 but also we kind
of want to get it here uh you know
attacking some of the pawns here so
bishop to d6 and now knight to c4 that
rapper goes back bishop to c7 keep an
eye on the pawn uh and nicely
controlling all of the squares that the
knight can jump to and now queen to d1
now magnus wants to shift the queen into
the attack with queen to g for queen to
f5 check
we have knight to f8 and still queen to
g4
uh we have knight to d7 maybe with an
idea of shifting the knight over to f6
but now king to f1 magnus is just
checking to see probably what rapper
will do because there's no rush you can
always play queen to f5 there's nothing
black can do about this now you can't
even play queen f6 because the knight
would hang
so here queen to e8 and now king back to
g2 by magnus queen to e7 rapper repeats
the position and only now queen to f5
check king to g8 and now g4 so just
grabbing more space here and preparing
g5
we have knights to f8 you do not want
this knight to remain a target here and
now magnus advances his pawn g5 and you
can see that um for the moment the
carlsen's knight is doing uh well
a lot more than rapport's knight and his
bishop is doing more than rapport's
bishop so
even though the the engine gives this
com position as a dead draw but uh if
you know if you're a human it's kind of
it's a bit more pleasant to have this
position with white than with black so h
captures on g5 bishop captures attacking
the queen here and now queen to c5 and
this is already maybe giving magnus a
bit too much wiggle room maybe f6 here
and then just uh ask black white what do
you do here now the bishop has to move
there aren't any
you know moves that you can throw in
between and then maybe only after this
then we play queen to f7
and then we prepare some pawn pushes
maybe we we threatened the knight here
so
also an option but okay uh the time on
the clock is low queen to c5 was played
and now attacking the knight knight back
to e3 and now magnus says do gobble up
the c3 pawn i dare you but if the pawn
is captured then h6 can be very very
annoying how do you how do you meet such
a move it's uh well this is just very
ugly but you don't even have to push h6
right away maybe even knights the g4 can
come and then all sorts of ideas become
possible here in front of the black king
so of course rapper doesn't grab that he
just goes back queen to d6
now with more control over the h6 square
and now magnus goes queen to g4 now he
says all right now the g file if it
opens up i'm going to have some very
nasty discoveries here and the situation
on the clock is magnus some three
minutes on the clock at upwards some two
minutes on the clock so g6 at
offers the trade here uh and now it's a
position where magnus really has to
consider a lot of things with the time
on the clock being very low so here if
you capture black's gonna capture and
how do you how do you continue here it's
a very nice position for why that's for
sure but is it uh you know nice enough
that's the question max is magnus
decides against this he plays bishop to
h6 first now the g file uh is uh well it
would be very unfortunate for for black
if it opens up but he also wants to
trade bishop for knight because that's a
very very strong defender so of course
rapper
prevents this he plays knight to d7 and
now we're basically down to one minute
and now we we we're kind of having a
bullet game with increment so knights to
c4 attacking the queen here and now uh
rapport is uh in a
well in a bit of a pickle here because
his queen is attacked and also if the
queen moves too far then the knight
hangs so the only move for black is
queen to e6 offering a queen trade but
it's also giving up upon for the moment
just captures captures in h captures and
g6 but not really because black can win
it with knights to see five now we're
attacking both of these spawns so i
would probably be playable for black
however uh rapport said all right you
attacked my queen i'm very low on the
clock i have to attack your queen there
is of course nothing better uh there is
but not with little time on the clock
but now the position is uh winning for
magnus however there is only one move
that wins the game so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on taking down the
leader of the tournament uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is queen to c8 with check that's
the good stuff and now of course the
king cannot move because the black queen
would be lost so we have to block with
the queen it's the only way to continue
the game now magnus trades uh queen
captures bishop captures and now the
only move that wins the game you kind of
had to see this if you went queen to c8
check bishop to g5 that's that's the
good stuff so what do you play here uh
black is completely tied down and you
don't really have a good move here if
king to g7 then we just play h6 check
and the king will not be defending this
knight so g captures an h5 was played
but now just bishop captures an f6 even
this is sufficient and here the knight
will be superior to the bishop uh bishop
captures an f6 now knight captures on a5
and that's the point of the combination
create a past a pawn
that's seemingly unstoppable or maybe it
is unstoppable so king to a f8 arapat of
course starts marching with his king
knight captures on c6 there's no way to
defend the pawn it's on a light square
we have king to e8 now comes knight to
b4
uh we have bishop to d8 preventing the
af the a pawn from marching forward now
knights to d3 going after the e5 pawn
and now f6 defending the spawn so magnus
is up upon but also the h5 pawn looks
very weak how are you stopping this pawn
from being captured it's a very very
hard position so king to g3 by magnus
king to d7 we have f3 improving the
position a little bit now comes bishop
to a5 attacking the pawn here and now c4
and you don't really have to worry uh
the black king is kind of close but as
you can see the pawns uh and the knight
are completely controlling all of the
squares here so there's no way for the
black king to you know reach any of them
so king to e6 and now king to h4 rapport
has to play something he plays f5 king
captures on h5 we have captures captures
and now king to d6 but now king to g6 we
have bishop to c7 and now just king to
f5 going after this pawn here so here
king to c6 but now magnus doesn't uh
rush with uh capturing of the of the e5
pawn because it could be could be a
little bit dangerous you know uh the
knight captures then you allow king to
c5 so why would you allow this so
instead magnus just brings the king into
the game with uh king to e6 and now king
to b6 we have king to d7 and not going
after the pawn of course
and now we have bishop to b8 and here
magnus just played c5 this comes with
check and he was in this position on
move 77 that rihard rapport resigned the
game and suffered his first loss in the
classical time format he's uh still
leading the tournament but magnus
corrupted him so now rapport is leading
only by uh by a half a point and magnus
is currently in in second place so we're
gonna discuss the standings a little bit
more because like i said we're gonna
check out the other two games as well uh
but now there's nothing for you to do
here you have to resign all of these
three squares are covered by the white
king and you're gonna start pushing that
pawn forward uh there's simply nothing
to do if you play some like king b7
we're just gonna deliver c6 check and if
king to b6 yes you're now covering this
square but then a5 check so there's
really nothing to play here you have to
move the king away um
these squares are covered so you have to
go back now we play c7 and after this is
uh captured knight captures on e5 and of
course the past epon is completely
winning
so of course rapport knows this uh he
knows this for quite quite a while now
as soon as they entered the in-game he
knew it but he had to try
uh so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it like i said we're gonna cover
all of them uh and uh like i said
rapport is still leading the tournament
by by a half point margin so two more
rounds to go if rapport can uh do do his
thing and continue winning in the
classical time section like he did for
the entire tournament so far uh then he
could still win the tournament we'll see
what happens um definitely
i would say he's definitely the favorite
to win it but uh we'll see a lot can
happen in two rounds so once again hope
you guys enjoyed it i would like to
thank steven chunley you stalk eight dot
com custom chess.com tom darrell and
isaac hits graph for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
all my previous videos here thank you
for watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the rest of
the games checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world thank you all i will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day